deux millions sept cent trente sept
mille personnes atteintes par le virus
192 1000 décès des 750 2000 guéri les
etats unis sont le pays le plus touché
avec 870 milka et plus de cinquante
mille décès l'europe recense plus d'un
million de cas et 130 113000 décès
l'espagne enregistrent 219 1764 cas et
22 mille cinq cent soixante quatre décès
en italie 190 mille cas et 25 milles 550
décès le royaume uni en fin à près de
140 mille cas et 18 1790 d'essai en
france nous surveillons la situation de
l'épidémie en population générale
vous le savez et c'est important de le
rappeler l'immense majorité des cas sont
des formes bénignes d'infection elles
sont prises en charge en ville par les
médecins généralistes par les médecins
traitants par les médecins sentinelles
et aussi par les laboratoires sentinelle
hier sos médecins a réalisé 316
intervention pour une suspicion de co
vide au cours de la journée soit 7 % de
l'activité totale c'est une activité en
baisse les services d'urgences signal
1397 passage soit 6% de leurs activités
liées aux copies de 19
c'est là aussi 6 % de leur activité
c'est aussi une activité en baisse mais
après passage on note 36%
d'hospitalisation et 3% d'admission
directe en réanimation enfin nous
surveillons l'activité des tests en
laboratoire et en particulier le taux de
positivité
ce taux de positivité moyen est de 20 %
il est de 36% à l'hôpital et de 17% en
ville les données hospitalières font
l'objet de remontées quotidiennes de la
part de 1324 établissements de santé
actuellement 28 1658 personnes sont
hospitalisés pour une infection qu'ovide
19 1346 nouvelles admissions de patients
atteints à l'hôpital c'est un solde
négatif aujourd'hui de 560 et une place
donc une bonne nouvelle
je vous rappelle que le nombre maximum
avait été atteint le 14 avril avec 32
mille 250 malades atteints de colite 19
4870 patients sont atteints de kobe 19
et nécessite des soins de réanimation
c'est encore un nombre très élevé le
nombre maximum de malades en réanimation
avait approché les 7200 le 9 avril au
cours des dernières 24 heures 155
nouveaux patients dans un état grave ont
été admis en réanimation c'est un nombre
c'est un nombre en baisse mais avec les
sorties ses 183 patients de moins
qui donc ce besoin baisse lentement mais
régulièrement et c'est un indicateur
important vous le savez de l'attention
de la mobilisation des équipes des
soignants des ressources logistiques
c'est un nombre qui reste encore très
élevé puisque en plus de tous ces
patients de réanimation il ya aussi des
patients en réanimation qui sont
atteints d'autres affections que le coc
vie de 19 dans les outre mer guadeloupe
guyane réunion martinique mayotte on
relève 94 hospitalisations dont 27 en
réanimation 43000 493 personnes guéries
sont sortis de l'hôpital
et vous savez qu'il existe aussi des
dizaines de milliers de personnes qui
ont été suivies en ville par leur
médecin généraliste et qui vont très
bien sans avoir besoin de passer par
l'hôpital
nous sommes donc face à une épidémie
massive sévère en moins de trois mois
près de 87 mille personnes atteintes ont
été hospitalisées et plus de quinze
mille personnes ont nécessité des soins
en réanimation
la circulation du virus reste à un
niveau élevé je vous ai donné le nombre
de nouveaux patients admis
à l'hôpital c'est quand même 1346
patients aujourd'hui c'est quand même 50
155 patients en réanimation nous devons
donc vraiment être pleinement mobilisés
respectez les gestes barrière qui
doivent devenir des gestes réflexes
nous surveillons attentivement la
situation des résidents des personnes
âgées des personnes vivant avec un
handicap dans les établissements sociaux
et médico-sociaux qui vous le savez
bénéficie de la présence de l'engagement
de 400 mille professionnels c'est 1615
établissements dont 4389 ehpad ont
signalé un épisode qu'ovide 19 à santé
publique francs sur le portail national
des signalements et les signalements
donc font état de 27 1880 cas confirmés
par test pcr depuis le 1er mars
en ce qui concerne la mortalité la
mortalité hospitalière tout d'abord nous
avons à déplorer 13850 deux décès depuis
le 1er mars 80 2 % de ces décès sont
intervenus chez des personnes de plus de
70 ans
nous notons aussi 34 décès outremer
en ce qui concerne la mortalité en ehpad
et en établissements médico sociaux
nous déplorons 8393 décès survenus dans
ces établissements
depuis le début de l'épidémie au total
en additionnant les décès survenus à
l'hôpital et ceux survenus en
institution depuis le 1er mars
nous déplorons 22 1245 des scènes en
plus de ces décès survenus à l'hôpital
et de cieux survenu en milieu
institutionnel en établissement nous
avons aussi la possibilité de surveiller
la mortalité générale en france toutes
causes confondues la mortalité qui est
déclarée après décès à l'hôpital
institution ou à domicile qui remonte
par l'état civil et par l'insee la
france participe d'ailleurs à l'échelon
européen à un consortium 10 euros momo
qui permet de comparer la morbidité la
mortalité dans plusieurs régions
européenne et pays européens et c'est
ainsi que nous constatons que plus de 12
pays et régions signalent un excès de
mortalité au cours de la semaine 15 la
semaine du 6 au 12 avril et donc la
france fait partie de nombreux pays qui
ont à déplorer cet excès de mortalité à
l'échelon national en france la
mortalité est en hausse sur la semaine
16 la semaine du 13 au 19 avril et
atteint désormais plus 24% par rapport à
l'attendu à l'échelon régional
un excès de mortalité émerge aussi au
cours de cette semaine dans six régions
centre val de loire ile-de-france grand
test auvergne rhône-alpes et bourgogne
franche comté ainsi que hot france et
l'île de france est à un niveau d'excès
exceptionnelle de mortalité cette
analyse se fait aussi où elle à
l'échelon départemental avec un excès de
mortalité
toujours pour la semaine 16 qui est
observé dans 25 départements d'île de
france de grand test des outrances de
bourgogne franche comté d'auvergne et
rhône-alpes et de centre val de loire
l'excès de mortalité concerne
majoritairement des personnes âgées de
plus de 65 ans nous avons aussi accès
aux certificats électroniques de décès
8104 décès conditionnait déjà une
mention d'infection par colis de 19 dans
les causes médicales de décès et ce sont
des certificats électroniques le décès
qui couvre la période depuis le 1er mars
cette notion de l'infection que 8,19 à
paraître dans 29% de l'ensemble des
décès certifiés par voie électronique en
france selon santé publique france il y
aurait 122 mille cinq cent soixante dix
sept cas confirmés
il est donc très important de rappeler
le respect strict des gestes barrières
du confinement toujours en cours de la
distanciation physique minimum d'un
mètre et la distanciation social avec la
réduction des contacts nous devons
poursuivre tous nos efforts collectifs
avec un seul objectif arriver aux plus
faibles niveaux de circulation du virus
selon 11 mai au plus faible nombre de
malades pris en charge en ville au plus
faible nombre
malade atteint de kovy 19 nécessitant
une admission à l'hôpital évidemment au
plus faible nombre de patients dans un
état grave
où suis vie de décès pour réussir
ensemble le déconfinement nous devons
respecter ensemble au mieux le
confinement les gestes barrières et les
mesures de distanciation je vous
remercie de questions pour europe 1
après le 11 mai or at on besoin d'une
attestation de déplacement qui aura été
réactualisé pour sortir ce sont les
règles de déconfinement qui ne sont pas
encore finalisés est-ce que les légions
d'euros logique constatées dans certains
services hospitaliers sur des malades du
coc u19 vous inquiète
oui mais on est logique que sont
toujours inquiétantes et on est toujours
très attentif à l'apparition de lésions
neurologiques
elles sont souvent observés chez des
malades de réanimation mais là encore il
faut que nous ayons des connaissances
scientifiques établis par les
réanimateurs pour objectiver ces lésions
neurologiques quand elles existent
parfois elles sont transitoires
parfois elles sont permanentes parfois
elles sont liées à des accidents
vasculaires cérébraux donc il ya de très
nombreuses causes et évidemment toutes
ces lésions neurologiques doivent faire
l'objet d'études spécifiques pour bien
préciser leur origine et leur
conséquence de questions pour ouest
france est la première en lien avec les
médias également des médecins
hospitaliers américains relève que le
coronavirus pourrait affecter le système
sanguin en provoquant des caillots
sanguins pouvant être la cause d'avc ces
symptômes sont il avéré et ont ils été
relevée chez des patients français
si cela était le cas des traitements
contre cette complication sont-ils ou
vont être vont ils être explorées oui là
ce sont des formes sévères qui sont
brossant c est signalé par de nombreuses
équipes médicales dans le monde
c'est une observation que l'on fait
régulièrement face à des infections
sévères parce que dans une infection
sévère il ya souvent une inflammation
majeur et on sait que l'inflammation
peut causer des thromboses peut causer
des cailloux c'est des textes écrits
dans de nombreuses affections peut être
des caillots veineuse à peu des caillots
artérielle après des caillots intra
pulmonaire et parfois ce que vous
décrivez des accidents vasculaires
cérébraux
il ya aussi des causes liées à
l'alitement
donc là encore les médecins réanimateurs
les médecins qui prennent en charge les
cas les plus graves ont l'habitude
d'être attentif aux complications
le type thromboemboliques qui sont
observées chez ces patients graves un
équipement masque grand public ne se
révéler assez onéreux une prise en
charge tout ou partie par l'état ou par
la sécurité sociale est elle envisagée
alors vous savez que ce sujet est porté
par bercy par les ministères de
l'économie
le présent d'un clic a été très clair il
souhaitait que les françaises et les
français est un accès facile aux masques
donc tout sera fait pour que dans les
prochains jours avant le déconfinement
il y ait un accès aisé pour tous les
français sur tout le territoire
à ces masques grand public de questions
pour france inter
vous avez dit hier devant les députés
que 99 % des patients contaminés avaient
développé des anticorps qu'ils étaient
protecteur ce qui évidemment très
rassurant sur quelles études vous basez
vous pour avancer ces chiffres pouvez
vous nous en dire un peu plus les
anticorps on tilt retrouver chez tous
les patients même un peu symptomatiques
sont ils tous protecteur et comment
sait-on si le son alors il ya eu
plusieurs études en cours vous savez que
la france est très mobilisé sur les
études en population et en particulier
des études de séroprévalence qui sont
proposés par exemple chez des
professionnels de santé par exemple
là encore sur des publications de
l'institut pasteur qui sont intéressés à
des jeunes dans l'oise
et donc c'est un élément important c'est
un élément rassurant c'est un élément
préliminaire parce que là encore il
faudra probablement plus d'études mais
c'est important que les françaises et
les français sachent que quand on a été
positif par pcr qu'on a fait l'infection
dans l'immense majorité des cas on
développe des anticorps ce qui avait
déjà été observé dans de très nombreuses
infections à coronavirus qui n'était pas
le cas ville mais qui était connu dans
les années précédentes donc il ya bien
une immunité qui apparaît une deux trois
semaines après l'infection
ça a été observée notamment chez des
jeunes adultes enel qui avait fait des
formes mineures qui n'avait pas été
hospitalisés donc c'est évidemment là
aussi rassurant et les équipes de
joueurs de chercheurs sont en train
d'analyser ces anticorps et considère
dans leurs résultats préliminaires
qu'ils ont eu la gentillesse de nous
transmettre que ce sont des anticorps
qui ont l'air protecteur donc tout ça ce
sont des bonnes nouvelles que l'on
souhaite
partager avec les françaises et les
français puisque nous avons toujours dit
que nous tirions ce que nous ne savions
pas mais que nous dirions immédiatement
ce que l'on apprenait jour après jour
une question pour la fp les armées ont
reconnu avoir effectué des achats de
chloroquine je cite si jamais la
chloroquine se révéler validée par les
autorités de santé comme étant utile
pour lutter contre locaux vides 19
cette position annonce-t-elle une
évolution de la halle d'autres du
gouvernement français en la matière et
si tel n'était pas le cas vous
semble-t-il normal qu'une institution de
la république se livre à de tels achats
préventif en arguant dans je cite
contexte de forte tension des
approvisionnements de matières premières
à usage pharmaceutique tensions qui ont
eu des conséquences dans le secteur
hospitalier public
je n'ai pas à commenter les décisions du
ministre des armées 3 questions pour la
paix m attend un bilan dur sur la prise
en charge des patients transférés en
dehors de leur région sortie de
ranimation retour dans leur région et la
façon dont ce retour est organisée lieu
d'hospitalisation retour à domicile
nous n'avons pas encore d'études
individuel évidemment pour rassurer tout
le monde
ces patients ont été transférés dans
d'excellentes conditions de sécurité
grâce à la mobilisation des équipes de
transport qui ont été massivement engagé
massivement mobilisés avec des
réanimateurs des infirmiers donc dans
des conditions de sécurité maximale je
pense d'ailleurs que nous ferons un
bilan complet de ces évacuations
sanitaires parce que nous avons appris
beaucoup et nous avons réussi c'est
d'évacuation très nombreuses 640
évacuations de malades de réanimation
par différents vecteurs aériens
hélicoptères bateaux et tgv médicalisé
donc il faudra que nous procédions à un
retour d'expérience et à une synthèse de
tout ce que nous avons fait notamment
pour soulager des équipes les plus
touchées et plus fortement impactée par
l'épidémie dans le grand est en
particulier mais aussi en othe france et
en ile de france mais nous n'avons aucun
élément de pronostics particulier sur
ses patients individuellement ils sont
pris en charge dans les hôpitaux plutôt
de l'ouest de la france ou du sud de la
france là où l'épidémie a - sévit et
donc ils sont plus en charge comme les
autres patients et dans des bonnes
conditions
selon reuters la france a allongé la
liste de médicaments dont elle interdit
l'exportation et cela ne plaît pas du
tout à la commission européenne
qui demandent justement a levé ses
restrictions sur des médicaments vitaux
quels sont les médicaments interdits
d'exportation en france l'europe n'était
elle pas prioritaire alors nous avons
pris des décisions très particulière
pour justement favoriser l'accès de
médicaments qui est en très forte
tension pour les établissements français
qui prenaient en charge des patientes
graves en réanimation
ce sont des mesures d'exception qui
permettent d'assurer le les
établissements qui en ont besoin dans
des conditions de d'extrême tension
d'avoir ces médicaments pour les
patients est il envisagé que le coc vie
19 devienne une maladie à déclaration
obligatoire notamment pour faciliter le
suivi de l'épidémie sur le territoire
alors c'est une très bonne question vous
savez qu'en france on a une trentaine de
maladies à déclaration obligatoire qui
nécessitent par exemple une déclaration
immédiate comme les méningites parce
qu'il faut prendre immédiatement des
mesures ou qui nécessitent tout
simplement une surveillance
épidémiologique
la différence entre ces trente maladies
à déclaration obligatoire et la maladie
kobe 19
c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de cas où comme
19 et que la vraie le vrai objectif de
la surveillance coville 19 c'est d'avoir
le maximum de cas testés dont toutes les
personnes symptomatique d'être capable
de faire du contact racing c'est à dire
d'affaires immédiatement dès qu'un
patient est détecté positif n'a été que
dès qu'une personne ait détecté porteuse
du virus de rechercher immédiatement ses
contacts de tester ses compacts et
ensuite d'isoler les contacts isolé
évidemment le malade et mettre en place
une 14ème et un suivi actif
donc c'est plutôt cet objectif là que
nous avons sur l'ensemble du territoire
national
être capable de détecter les personnes
symptomatique de détecter leurs contacts
et de les prendre en charge dans les
meilleures conditions pour éviter que le
virus ne circule de questions pour radio
france quel est le nombre de tests pcr
réalisées à ce jour hospitalier labaude
ville en ehpad établissements
médico-sociaux autres laboratoires du
vétérinaire aux recherches et le nombre
de tests sérologiques sur personnel
soignant notamment si l'on commençait
alors vous savez que l'objectif
en france est désormais très clair nous
devons tester les malades nous devons
tester des personnes symptomatique nous
devons tester les cas contact de ces
personnes devront tester les
professionnels de santé les personnes
dans les établissements de santé
lorsqu'il ya des cas et puis bien sûr
cette stratégie de dépistage prioritaire
pour les ehpad pour leur part à m
lorsqu'il ya des cas de savoir quelle
est la présence du virus parmi les
résidents quelle est la présence du
virus parmi les personnels pour pouvoir
les aider à organiser les soins à
organiser la vie de l'ehpad en secteur
atteint ou non atteint pour protéger au
maximum les résidents et le ministre en
a reparlé aujourd'hui nous nous
augmentons notre capacité de jour en
jour nous sommes désormais à plus de 40
mille tests pcr par jour vous voyez que
nous sommes vraiment mobilisés pour
réaliser nos objectifs
au vu des dernières données de
pharmacovigilance et parce que la
majorité des cas sont apparus à
l'hôpital est il envisagé dans tes
rendre certains bradeux l'essai clinique
discovery en particulier le bras hydroxy
chloroquine à quel stade pendant cette
décision alors ça c'est un point très
important lorsqu'il ya un essai
thérapeutique
il peut être interrompue n'importe quand
n'importe quel jour s'il ya un signal
négatif c'est à dire s'il ya des décès
si on sent que il y a un impact négatif
pour des personnes qui prennent un
traitement appartement où apparaissent
des effets indésirables graves où il ya
visiblement un désavantage majeur dans
un bras versus un vote il peut être
interrompue à n'importe quel moment
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le cas ce n'est
pas le cas de laisser discovery qui fait
l'objet d'une analyse intermédiaire et
ce n'est pas le cas d'autres essais mais
ça arrive régulièrement dans l'histoire
des et thérapeutique que des bras soit
interrompue parce que l'effet est
défavorable et évidemment il n'y a
aucune raison de poursuivre l'inclusion
de patients sous traitement lorsque ce
traitement quel que soit son trait de ce
traitement d'ailleurs s'avère
défavorable pour le patient une question
pour hospimedia
dans le cadre de l'art de leur
réouverture progressive
les aides seront il fournit un masque
pour leurs travailleurs en situation de
handicap par le truchement des circuits
logistiques des établissements et
structures médico sociales alors c'est
tout ce que nous mettons en place la
stratégie d'accès aux masques soit pour
les institutions médico social et social
soit pour les personnes qui sont
exposées donc là encore dans les
prochains jours
nous aurons des explications très
claires à fournir l'ensemble des
travailleurs et à l'ensemble des
structures
concernant l'accès aux masques soit dans
le cadre des masques soignants ou du du
champ médico-social soit dans l'axé au
masque grand public question pour le
wall street journal
qu'est ce que la france fera avec la
surcapacité des lits des soins intensifs
aux hôpitaux et comment est ce que la
france va organiser ces hôpitaux qu'on
va faire ce qu'on vit 19 dans le moyen
terme
est ce que la france va garder cette
capacité si un rebond des cas alors sur
la capacité en soins intensifs je
rappelle que nous avons doublé notre
capacité de réanimation ce qui était
totalement inédit et ce qui s'est fait
en quelques jours donc une prouesse des
équipes hospitalières
nous avons des doubler ses capacités et
nous avons encore besoin de ses
capacités augmenter puisque je vous ai
parlé du nombre de patients qu'aux vide
en réanimation mais il ya aussi des
patients atteints d'autres pathologies
graves
donc nous avons encore besoin de ces
lits nous espérons évidemment que le
besoin olives à se réduire
nous avons aussi besoin de garder une
capacité de réponse face à un éventuel
risque de reprise épidémique
si il y à un rebond 6 lits à prendre en
charge des cas groupés
donc nous avons à la fois à revenir
petit à petit vers une activité normale
hospitalière vous savez que nous avons
une très forte mobilisation grâce à la
déprogrammation
nous avons interrompu des activités
programmées de médecine de chirurgie les
établissements de santé privés se sont
mobilisés aussi pour aider les
établissements publics donc tous ces
établissements se sont réorganisés nous
allons petit à petit adapter notre
posture pour permettre de reprendre une
activité normale je rappelle que nous
encourageons les patients atteints de
pathologies chroniques ou de pathologies
aiguës à consulter leur médecin ou à
consulter des services d'hospitalité les
suivent donc il ne faut pas hésiter à se
rendre à l'hôpital si on a besoin
d'aller à l'hôpital mais nous avons en
permanence besoin de garder une posture
vigilante l'épidémie n'est pas terminée
pour pouvoir prendre en charge tous les
patients une question pour france 24 on
lit depuis le début de la crise que le
virus peut rester actif plusieurs heures
voire plusieurs jours sur des surfaces
inertes comme le papier ou le plastique
y at il des confirmations scientifiques
sur ces hypothèses si oui la charge
virale sur ces surfaces est-elle aussi
forte que dans la salive
alors c'est très compliqué parce que
fait ce sont des tests qui recherchent
le virus mais pas forcément
un virus vivants qui est capable
d'infecter mais par contre ça envoie un
message très clair c'est que la
contamination se fait souvent par les
mains et c'est pourquoi je rappelle
l'importance des gestes barrières une
question pour diaspora news magazine à
l'instar de la grippe qui est
saisonnière peut-on évoquer une
saisonnalité du coronavirus alors on
n'en sait pas grand chose puisque comme
je vous le dit régulièrement ce virus
est émergent il est arrivé depuis trois
mois donc nous savons pas comment il va
se comporter cet été et s'il reviendra
et sous quelle forme
il reviendra à un autre à une autre
saison mais effectivement l'immunité
collective le l'organisation mondiale de
la santé le rappeler est faible tant que
cette immunité collective n'est pas
élevé et tant que nous n'avons pas soit
un médicament curatif soit un vaccin
le virus peut continuer à circuler sur
la planète
3 questions pour mehdi site le directeur
du cdc aux usa craint une deuxième vague
de kobe 19 plus meurtrière car elle
coïnciderait avec le retour de la grippe
qu'en pensez vous c'est une hypothèse
que nous devons évidemment envisagé
puisque comme je vous le disais
l'immunité collective n'est pas atteinte
après savoir si ce virus va circuler
avec le virus grippal personne n'en sait
rien mais effectivement nous devons être
attentifs à l'évolution dans les
prochaines semaines et les prochains
mois
8500 respirateur légers ont été
commandées par la france selon la
société de réanimation de langue
française ses modèles aux iris ont été
conçus pour le transport des malades et
non la réanimation et ne doivent être
utilisés qu'en dernier recours en cas de
kovy de 19,2 nouveau respirateur moins
légers sont ils en cours de fabrication
et si oui combien
oui vous savez que nous avons commandé
de très nombreux respirateur l'objectif
n'est pas uniquement de prendre en
charge des patients qu'aux vide mais
bien de d'avoir un parc de respirateurs
moderne et donc il ya effectivement des
respirateurs lourds qui sont destinés à
les blocs opératoires qui sont destinés
à la réanimation de patients graves en
réanimation et puis il ya aussi besoin
et nous l'avons bien montré lors des
évacuations sanitaires de respirateurs
moderne le respirateur 9 pour nous
transporte sa mue pour nous transporte
d'ambulances de l'animation pour les
évacuations sanitaires de minecraft qui
ont besoin d'être transférés d'un
service à un autre ou vers un plateau
technique donc ce sont de toute façon
des matériels neufs qui seront utiles
pour les établissements français
des chercheurs chinois viennent de
démontrer que la climatisation facilite
la transmission du virus dans les
espaces fermés
cela pourrait-il orienter des directives
à destination des ehpad et hôpitaux
équipés de climatisations puis à
destination des commerces et transports
etc ou en commun climatisé lors du
déconfinement alors ce sont des données
qui mérite évidemment d'être confirmée
vous savez qu'aujourd'hui nous avons la
confirmation que le virus se transmet
essentiellement par les gouttelettes et
par des mains souillées
il y a une possibilité qui a été
effectivement évoqué qu'il y à un
aérosol une aérosols isation du virus
dont potentiellement à risque avec
l'animation sans climatisation ce risque
n'est pas démontré il n'y a pas eu de
situations réelles où le virus est
transmis par la climatisation mais nous
avons saisi dès les excite les experts
pour savoir si oui ou non nous nous
devions prendre des mesures spécifiques
face au risque viral et la présence de
climatisation une agence pour l'agent ce
qu une question pour l'agent scully
aujourd'hui à combien de tester ton par
jour qui reçoit ces tests
après le 11 mai qui sera testée alors
nous avons toujours la même stratégie
tester les malades tester les
professionnels de santé et les ehpad
nous élargissons à la demande du
président de la république notre
capacité de tests sur tout le territoire
national pour pouvoir pour pouvoir
tester toutes les personnes
symptomatique nous avons déjà plus de 40
me taise par jour une question pour ces
news comment se fait-il que malgré le
confinement le nombre d'hospitalisations
reste toujours aussi élevées alors le
nombre d'hospitalisations baisse il faut
quand même rappeler que nous avons
régulièrement de semaine en semaine de
jour en jour moins de patients
hospitalisés c'est quand même une bonne
nouvelle nous restons quand même un
niveau important c'est pourquoi il ne
faut pas baisser la garde
pourquoi ces patients sont arrivés à
l'hôpital parce qu'ils se sont
contaminées quelque part mais vous savez
que le confinement n'est pas absolu il
ya des gens qui travaillent
il ya des gens qui ont une activité
professionnelle qui doivent sortir qui
ont forcément des activités en dehors de
leur rôle de leur lieu de vie et donc
c'est pour ça que nous encourageons en
permanence dès que l'on sort du foyer
des condenseurs de son domicile
l'application stricte des gestes
barrières la distance permanente entre
les personnes la distanciation sociales
la réduction du nombre de contacts
c'est ainsi que nous continuerons grâce
aux efforts de tous à être efficace et à
freiner cette épidémie 3 questions pour
terra gora comment concilier le
confinement individuel port du masque et
le retour en classe les enfants devront
ils portent un masque et les enseignants
alors c'était ce sont des travaux qui
sont en cours puisque jean castex est
chargée d'organiser le déconfinement
mais il y a une évidence a rappelé pour
tous les français c'est que nous aurons
besoin après la sortie de ce confinement
d'appliquer tous ensemble les gestes
barrière à quel taux de tva à 2,1 pour
cent cinq mille 5 5% 10% 20% seront
soumis les masques grand public qui sont
considérés comme des produits de
première nécessité dans le cadre du
déconfinement faudra demander à bercy
quand seront disponibles en ville les
tests de dépistage du court aux navires
us qu'elle sera l'art nature sérologique
et ou en donne à zale alors c'était sont
disponibles en ville les laboratoires
font un travail remarquable
vous savez que nous avons nous mobiliser
toutes nos forces et laboratoires
hospitaliers et laboratoires de
recherche et laboratoires d'analysés de
biologie médicale donc le les
laboratoires en ville sont déjà très
mobilisés et font déjà beaucoup de tests
notamment des tests virologiques puisque
les tests virologiques sur les tests
qu'il faut utiliser aujourd'hui pour
détecter des personnes symptomatique des
personnes porteuses du virus
je remercie c'est la dernière question
merci à vous